hey how do you get into shooting dope i
mean i know it's obvious like did you
start with viking and you went to oxy
and then you're like [ __ ] it's just
cheaper to get heroin or like what's the
psychology because not a lot of people
but not a lot of people decide to inject
in their vein like what was that
decision like the first time injecting
into your veins so no i didn't start
with the pills it kind of went from you
know the herb to the blow
to i sold i did grateful dead tour for a
little bit
wait what year uh
96
95 95. jerry died in 95. yeah well i was
supposed to be no yeah because i was
supposed to be at the last show they
played unbroken chain at at charlotte
coliseum which is where i got arrested
so i didn't get to see him play the song
so
definitely 95 because i was at that show
and before my reference of years is
[ __ ] but
that was the first time i was arrested
at 17 and in mecklenburg i ended up
going to mecklenburg state penitentiary
because you're an adult at 17 from the
[ __ ] grateful dead show but point
being is when i got into dead tour i got
into it for selling drugs and like
making good money not sure for the music
me too man i went to every single show
on the east coast 94 tour
of the grateful dead what kind of drugs
are you guys
probably
maybe then but a little right after so i
might have just missed you i mean dude i
would show up to the show
like with my car on fumes you know i had
it i had this use car it'd be on fumes
and i would like go like do a backflip
for like you know like a buck or
something like five backflips for a
dollar and then i'd be like okay cool
like i've got five bucks and then i
would like
for five bucks i would go to a dead head
and get like three hits of assets yeah
and then i would take each hit of acid
and go sell them for five bucks now i've
got 15 bucks and then i would take that
15 bucks and go buy like an eight of
wheat that's it and then like once i ate
the wheat i would sell that for like
[ __ ] 30 bucks and now i got 30 bucks
and i go and [ __ ] buy a bag of
mushrooms it's just a constant come up
so i was riding for pal at the time and
i would go and i'd have boxes of boards
and i'm just selling boards on the lot
trading them for tickets no you name it
yeah and so you're a fan of grateful
dead music yeah i love it i noticed that
i listened to it more now with my age
i'm just kind of at that point
i love it dude
i've kind of come back i missed the
whole fish era that didn't really do it
for me because i did dead tour so i was
like yeah not my but anyway so i'm
i meet up with this guy
out of san francisco who who lays
uh grams of acid lays crystal grams so
we're getting like
20
10 packs at a time books 10 packs of
sheets of water so that's how it hits
like a sheet has a hundred years this is
a thousand in a book
okay so i'm getting like this guy's
coming with the raw gram and he's
actually laying it in a hotel and me and
a couple other dead you know we go in
and
i get this paper one night and the guy
who's gonna buy a few books doesn't have
all the cash but he has some heroin how
much would a book be for me at that at
that level where i was getting it right
from the guy in the grams like three
four hundred bucks and then how much can
you make of that for a thousand thousand
hits and this is back in ninety five
thousand hits or five bucks a hit that's
five thousand to your turn to see more
than ten times in your money easily but
i wasn't doing that i was still selling
in books for like 800
and still doing great because we had so
much if you get caught with a book
they charge with attempting to overthrow
the government
with them i mean dude they're like the
grateful dead tour there are still
people in prison yeah the grateful dead
drew was just a [ __ ] left a just in
its wake just
people in prison for decades yeah it was
gnarly how did you how do you know that
your documentary i don't know if it was
a documentary but we're just friends
like you know facts it's [ __ ] it's
widely known i didn't care about
overthrowing the government but i know
that like like a lot of acid if you've
got lsd that's a [ __ ]
heavy crime it's serious how long do you
go to jail for if you get caught
overthrowing the government
i don't know
i'm starting the government but
is it because it's beheaded it's like
you can brainwash people to or something
like that
but we still didn't get to the heroine
yeah
so i sold this guy
to the back of the hair
and the heroine and if you didn't know
he's sober too guys
and here we go
and if you need help call me
um i i i if you're buying books
yeah
we have a guy flying in from san
francisco who's laying raw grams and and
that leaves us with lots of books and uh
one night this guy was short on the cash
so he gave us some heroin
and i was like cool whatever paid no
mind to it what kind of heroin tar no
he flew in from san francisco we were in
baltimore so it was like just white raw
dope not like the west coast chiva tar
and i just put it in my sock drawer like
totally didn't think about it forgot
about it
a few days later we're catching the
greyhound bus to i forget what show it
was we were jumping back on tour
and my buddy's like you got the dope and
i'm like oh yeah cool so
in my mother's bedroom and my mother's
house at
six just turned 17. how much job was it
it was like 200 bucks worth okay so
what's that like um
maybe like a
gram of raw heroin so you don't get a
lot there um but we did it and i ended
up
snored it and insanely threw up
so that continued on
but how i went from that to shooting it
was well because snorting it's just
[ __ ] wasteful did you like it when
you started it yeah i loved it yeah but
you you build a tolerance yeah right and
you need more and you got to spend more
and spend more to to get that same high
and certainly like everybody does harem
for their first time they're like i
would never never shoot up but then
you're snorting it or smoking it and
like you develop a tolerance it's not
getting you right and you're like [ __ ]
man like and then i'm heroin and i just
like i can't not shoot up because it's
just not economical and i want to
actually get that feeling stronger and
then someone like me comes along and
says dude if you [ __ ] shoot up like a
half of a dime bag you'll be just as
high as sniffing that 300 and you know
what i mean and so all of a sudden
shooting up is not so taboo anymore did
you ever shoot anybody up for their very
first time no i wasn't good at i could
do me but how do you learn how to shoot
up like i know a buddy of mine who was
in there and watched a youtube video
i i was [ __ ] advanced like i didn't
do that i just i i would give someone a
little bit
can you look up on youtube how to shoot
up heroin
box that's insane
how do i use a needle yeah how to so
that but how do you who teaches you that
so i would give somebody a little bit to
do it for me at first what a [ __ ] and
then oh absolutely and then after i got
tired of giving it to him i learned real
quick so you know buddy let me do your
piece of [ __ ] if you if you shoot
somebody up for the first time yeah but
i mean you you are but you're already so
disconnected from reality that like why
would that not make sense yes
no there's no ethics and morals involved
of like
when you're
smacked up at that point were you ever
in a situation where someone od'd and
everyone's like let's dip or like throw
them in a dumpster no no that's [ __ ]
callous
even at that point i don't know if i
would it happens right
in time nah i i like to think of myself
as a [ __ ] junkie with morals like i i
actually was like uh i think a good
person here hold on to this hundred for
me yeah
but i wouldn't let you die
right did you find anything
oh my god so this is safer
heroin injecting
how to do it the safest way possible it
started he was like washing his hands at
the beginning there you go
720
in how long
what how long is the video three minutes
you know
okay
yeah how many months has it been out or
how many years sorry it's it's eight
years it's been out so maybe it's the
video your buddy saw it could be
wow
so when you're shooting up like what are
you you're flicking it to get the
bubbles out because you'll die if a
bubble gets into your veins they would
say that an air bubble could create
something in your veins
you know i just did it because that's
just what i saw other people doing yeah
and i didn't want to like
yeah i wasn't reinventing the wheel here
and the first time you get shot up with
it you're just like oh dear god so the
first time i got shot up with though was
not that way right so i'm sniffing i'm
sniffing it and then my girlfriend at
the time we're driving through this
reservoir and she nods out and my head
and gets a car accident and my head goes
through the windshield right so i'm in
the hospital and they have me with all
these ivs um and a guy brings me heroin
to the room and he just puts it right
into the iv but then goes in my arm
did he have to cook it on a spoon yeah
in the hospital
in the hospital room and then that was
my first
you know way of injecting it oh yeah did
you like it i loved it so do you know
when
in the hood
when addicts get really bad and they
kind of blow out of their veins and they
have to go to the hospital and the
hospital puts an iv in
they'll leave with the iv just because
they have a direct main line yeah
because they can't hit it on their own
holy moly right you don't want to close
that door
so they'll like legit go there to get
them to run an iv on you for whatever
they say they need or however they can
make it happen and then
walk out of the hospital with the
[ __ ]
bag
how long is that good for how long can
you keep it i don't know these still
falls out yeah i'm sure they're not
super worried did you ever have
abscesses
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because
it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude